okay let's talk fashion for a second
here let's just yeah started off tell me
a secret about this dress well it was a
made it by Armani Prive and it's got its
like sparkly and shiny and Dinkins up
yes describe the look in one word I'm
gonna have to say you know what I feel
very me tonight it's just kind of pink
it's like a lot going on and just ready
that's best self yes this is my best
self okay painful thing you did to fit
into the outfit hmm I'm gonna have to
say this one was pretty this one was
pretty easy it's not what's pretty good
it comfortable it is it yeah I mean it's
not I wouldn't say comfortable but it's
definitely not one of the most
uncomfortable things everyone it's
actually pretty comfortable okay now
bought borrowed stolen explain oh this
flame yeah what on you is vaccaro to
soul ooh okay I guess this is this is
borrowed cuz you know these are diamonds
weird bear yet this is a but cuz there's
custom made and stolen I guess is my
face and body from my jeans of my other
family members thank you very much oh my
gosh and the first thing I'm gonna do
eat when I take this outfit I actually
have it all planned out okay and I've
actually told three people today tonight
I'm eating all the Mexican food tomorrow
for lunch I'm having a Five Guys Burgers
and Fries and at night I'm having pasta
and probably southern food somewhere in
between
I'll even think about this for why yeah
cuz I've had to like eat healthy and
stuff for this and now I'm so I'm sorry
I'm just so bored of it I'm ready - I'm
ready to chow down now what can we
expect from your opening performance you
know what um I definitely feel a little
bit nervous right now but that I think
the more nerves the better the show okay
you know but the bass basically it's
based on my family it's based on
specifically kind of my grandma's
upbringing
you know raised in Havana in this thing
called a solar Dominator which is
basically like a poor person's it's like
a big house but every family has one
room in the house and they there's like
a common patio that everybody shares and
some musicians would go and like Jim out
and stuff and my grandma would always be
there dancing and like singing with
people and so the whole thing is
basically based off that vibe it's like
a big Latin block party so it should it
should hopefully it will feel like a
party
[Music]